[Music]
right but we begin tonight with more
fake news from CNN this time it is
spewing from the lips of the Clinton
news network president his name is Jeff
Zucker
and according to The Hollywood Reporter
sucker recently blasting Fox News is
quote a propaganda machine and state-run
TV now by the way Fox News like every
newspaper in the country they have a
sports page they have a news page and
gossip page and they have an editorial
page Oh opinion programming he even went
on to say that this network does quote a
disservice to the country now this is
coming from the man whose so-called
cable news station CNN is literally
nicknamed the bleep hole Network because
they have an obsession with the word you
might remember this is there a
difference if the president said whole
house do you think these countries are
poles Donald Trump has turned the Oval
Office into a hope bowlers built this
country a hundred and ten years ago in
addition to the president comments
yesterday a few more poll countries
hold-hold country rich do you have any
example of any coal country that the
president referred to that is
predominantly Caucasian polish poles
bowlers oh I work for Boulder Paul I'm
proud to be a polar in a million years I
would be saying all on television Jeff
Zucker is bleep whole network well they
also have a new obsession basically
softcore pornography from the nonstop
coverage of stormy Daniels to the
constant speculation about an alleged
affair between Trump and a pornstar if
you're looking for 24/7 never-ending
looped around porn related news CN n
fake news they have you covered take a
look this could be the last nail in the
coffin for McDaniels it's causing stormy
weather pornstar stormy Daniels claims
President Trump
broke the law had her bullied the stormy
Daniels had the president's number it
sure seems that way
the President Trump might have met his
match with stormy Daniels
how is stormy weather in this
or me speaks we're hearing quite a bit
from stormy Daniels stormy in her own
words isn't going anywhere
stormy Daniels has a good lawyer the
pornstar stormy Daniels was telling the
truth stormy Daniels
is on a tear quick preview is stormy
Daniels interview this Sunday breaking
news the stormy Daniels stormy Daniels
stormy Daniels stormy Daniels throw me
Daniels is stormy Daniels stormy Daniels
stormy Daniels the reason he can't
engage with stormy Daniels is because
she's got his number it's about an
alleged affair not proven and of course
very different from Bill Clinton and
wanting to Broderick Kathleen Willey
and of course Paula Jones but CNN's
obsessive 24/7 coverage doesn't end with
stormy Daniels they're also now giving a
former Playboy Playmate Karen McDougal
they're giving her plenty of airtime and
again we're talking about potentially
alleged consensual relationships and
we're going to compare how they covered
Oh assaults and exposing oneself and
even rape with Bill Clinton all this
effort of course in this case to destroy
Donald Trump take a look so when was the
next communication I believe we talked
right away in the phone and I think we
talked for about a week on the phone
before his next visit to LA and that was
his birthday which i think is june 12th
would he would he call you he would call
me I would call him vice versa CNN's new
obsession and we might have a brand new
name for their leader there their chief
their CEO Jeff Zucker the porn king of
cable news and of course porn king Jeff
Zucker and his colleagues over at the
bleep hole Network they are not alone in
their stormy obsession NBC ABC CBS and
others also featuring saturated coverage
of this story
now predictably the same level of media
interest was not present back in the
early 1990s when then President Bill
Clinton was accused of having multiple
extramarital affairs and even worse
engaging in serious instances of sexual
misconduct by the way in the case of
Jennifer flowers
she was proven right but I remember
James Carville oh he worked and he was
one of the people talking about it or
dragging a dollar through a trailer park
about Paula Jones remember Paula Jones
she accused Bill Clinton of
literally pulling down his pants and
exposing himself and according to the
media Research Center in the first three
days of that scandal ABC provided a
whopping 16 seconds of coverage NBC CBS
they ignored it and next there's the
case of Kathleen Willey and she said
that Bill Clinton groped grabbed fondled
touched hissed her against her will
inside the Oval Office that story breaks
how's your fake news handle it
ABC ignores it NBC CBS gave it a
whopping 34 seconds of coverage again
according to the media Research Center
CNN meanwhile they dedicated 26 seconds
of coverage during their evening
newscast then of course you have the
serious allegation of rape Juanita
Broderick and I interviewed Juanita
Broderick one of the toughest interviews
I ever did the surface first in 1998
Media Research Center tells us ABC CBS
totally ignored the breaking story NBC
aired seven minutes of coverage but not
before initially spiking its pre taped
interview with Juanita Broderick now
this proves what I have been saying
about journalism since what 2007 or
eight it's dead and buried in this
country we'll have more on this later in
the show also tonight Sean Dow the lead
lawyer for president Trump's legal team
for dealing with Robert Muller's
witch-hunt has resigned and just a few
hours ago Fox has confirmed that
Victoria ton Singh will be joining the
president's legal team and president
Trump is also breaking news tonight
saying that he would like to do a
sit-down with a special counsel let's
delve into this
[Music]
I'm sure the president would and my
advice to the president you got to be
very careful I've been warning everybody
about Robert Muller and his merry band
of Democratic donors we know for a fact
Robert Muller is conducting a biased
partisan totally flawed investigation he
has gone way beyond his mandate mullahs
original purpose it was supposed to be
about finding evidence of Trump Russia
collusion but we haven't found it in
over a year almost a year and a half now
now that's why he was appointed it is
not what he is doing as constitutional
law expert and Liberal Democrat
Professional Professor Alan Dershowitz
of Harvard he is pointing out the
special counsel councils exist to bring
about charges justify their existence
doesn't matter if it is on all connected
to what they're supposed to be
investigating they have to do all of
this to justify their existence at an
enormous cost not only to the American
taxpayers all of you but also to the
culture and society now this Muller
witch-hunt has been going on for over a
year and so far I found nothing
regarding Trump Russia collusion and the
president by the way has every reason to
be upset and here's why
Muller's team has more democratic donors
than a liberal Hollywood fundraiser and
not one of Muller's partisan witch
hunters donated a Trump every single
Republican in Washington not named
Donald Trump would crack under this kind
of pressure
so yes completely understandable when
you appoint a team that donates to Obama
the DNC Hillary Clinton and they're all
going after one guy and not one person
that donated a Trump of course the
president wants to fight back because
the special counsel from day one has
been abusively biased and many on that
team have questionable ethics they have
horrific backgrounds and they're out to
destroy him by the way saying I'm not
guilty that's how any innocent person
would act now Rob Rosenstein he has
stacked the deck against President Trump
by appointing his buddy Robert Muller
and he has conflicts himself
and then James Comey admitted he leaked
the memos to get the special counsel
appointed and of course it happened this
is one big giant incestuous deep state
cabal that is trying to unseat a duly
elected president I will more on that
now also breaking this hour a charm
Masters has resigned as the national
security adviser and he will be replaced
by john bolton this is a huge
improvement we'll have more on that and
tonight the House Judiciary Chairman Bob
Goodlatte is issued a subpoena to the
DOJ demanding documents on this fixed
Clinton email investigation which never
was an investigation also about severe
FISA abuse and on Andrew McCabe's firing
and chairman Goodlatte he notes in a
press release and this is something we
have been reporting on Congress has now
requested 1.2 million DOJ FBI documents
related to the Clinton investigation the
Inspector General has them
why won't they turn them over the hills
reporting the chairman Goodlatte is
trying to determine whether or not call
me light under oath he's requesting
those documents as well and so far
Congress has only received of the 1.2
million 3,000 well that sounds like
obstruction that doesn't sound like the
wheels of justice or equal justice under
the law the DOJ stonewalling they're
preventing Congress from conducting
their constitutional job which is
oversight remember rod Rosenstein
sucking up to Paul Ryan in the final
hours please don't let congress have
access to the truth about paese
abuses and we all know the Clinton email
investigation was a sham but this Comey
struck Lisa Paige McCabe and probably
Loretta Lynch all part of putting to fix
it and on FISA abuses the memos have
exposed that the FBI and DOJ used what
unverified because they're not true
clinton bought and paid for dossier
russian lies to get a FISA judge to get
a warrant to spy on Carter Paige Trump
associate which then allows them to spy
on the entire Trump campaign and we know
the bulk of the FISA application
according to the Grassley Graham memo
was made up of the phony Clinton dossier
full of Russia and Russian government
lies in propaganda and as Andrew McCabe
testified without no dossier and never
would have even been a FISA warrant
application and as for McCabe his
comments after being fired well could
put his buddy James Comey in serious
legal jeopardy remember in a statement
mccabe writes in part the OIG
investigation is focused on information
i chose to share with the
Porter through my public affairs officer
and a legal counselor as deputy director
I was one of only a few people who had
the authority to do that and it was not
a secret it took place over several days
and others including the director were
aware of the interaction with the
reporter though he's not addressing
lying under oath so according to McCabe
Coby knew he was leaking information to
the media which is in part why mccabe
got fired and then lying under oath also
contributed well mccabe is saying now is
very different one James Comey said back
in May of 2017 who do you believe call
me or McCabe we'll let you decide
director Comey have you ever been an
anonymous source in those reports about
matters relating to the Trump
investigation or the Clinton
investigation never questioned to one
relatively related
have you ever authorize someone else at
the FBI to be an anonymous source in
news reports about the Trump
investigation or the Clinton
investigation no now you got a wonder of
Georgie Stephanopoulos over at ABC
Clinton's BFF and the Liberals on the
view and Stephen Colbert and fake Jake
over at CNN fake news and Rachel Maddow
you think they're gonna ask mr. deep
State James Comey about any of this
we're not gonna hold our breath but
James commis welcome on this show our
invitation continues now what is
becoming more apparent by the day is how
the deep state is fighting back as they
continue to get exposed they're not
liking what is now happening and we are
exposing on the show the perfect
examples former Obama CIA director John
Brennan he is now trying to malign
president Trump with a brand new
conspiracy theory let's take a look I
think he's afraid of the President of
Russia why well I think one could
speculate as to why that the Russians
may have something on him personally
that they could always roll out and make
his life more difficult clearly I think
it's important for us to be able to
improve relations with Russia but the
fact that he has has had this fawning
attitude toward mr. Pugh
has not said anything negative about him
I think continues to you know say to me
that he does have something to fear
great now he's a known liar but the
media just parrots Brennan's talking
points let's look at this the former CIA
director who's worked for presidents on
both sides of the aisle is deeply
concerned it's so clear at this point
that Vladimir Putin and his associates
somebody has something on Donald Trump
the big question we're asking today why
does this president feel the way he does
about Vladimir Putin that may be
something that turns the key and the
Russia probe is figuring out why this
president is so deferential to Putin and
to Russia and if there is some sort of
compromise that they have on him
president Trump has been 50 times harder
on Russia than Obama ever was and he's
about to take the legs out of Vladimir
Putin's economy and he's not whispering
oh - Vladimir after the election I'll
have more for Brewery
Brenna's also threatening president
Trump let's take a look at his tweet
when the full extent of your venality
moral turpitude and political corruption
becomes known you will take your place
as a disgraced demagogue in the dustbin
of history you may speak goat andy
mccabe but you will not destroy America
America will triumph over you okay John
Brennan who voted for a communist for
president a deep state swamp rat who's
losing his mind and all of his friends
now are being exposed here's a little
Hannity history lesson on Brennan that
the media won't tell you as I said he
admitted to voting for quote a communist
party candidate how did you ever become
the CIA director you have to wonder and
maybe Robert Muller should see if he's
ever colluded with the Russians and
that's not all the New York Post has
reported that the house Intel committee
is investigating John Brennan and his
ties to the Clinton bought and paid for
dossier and the same committee is now
looking into whether Brennan committed
perjury when he testified under oath
like his buddy McCabe who is he claimed
to have no idea who paid for that
dossier and the post also reporting that
John Brennan briefed members of Congress
including former Democratic Senator
Harry Reid about that pony dossier and
if you remember Reid then put out a
statement after meeting with Brennan
days after before the
and reference the dossier because
Brennan told him so Brennan is dirty
political and corrupt as they come and
now he's lashing out because we're all
finding out who he really is we have
even more breaking news to tell you
about the house Intel committee has put
an end to this Russia investigation 14
months and they will had a vote to
release the public to the public the
Republic of members final report and the
house Intel committee released a summary
of the key findings today here are the
highlights after 14 months interviews
with over all these witnesses the
committee found no evidence of Trump
Russian collusion 1 so the liberal media
all you Democrats have been lying to the
American people James clapper number two
former Obama Director of National
Intelligence Oh fake new CNN contributor
well he provided inconsistent testimony
about his contacts with the media I
guess Comey is gonna get hired next and
then Brennan and then who knows maybe
they'll hire stormy and by the way of
members of the partisan press are
watching we first reported this last
week
it's called investigative journalism
real news you guys might want to try it
sometime instead of spinning these
conspiracy theories and by the way this
wouldn't be the first time clapper has
lied to Congress back in May of 2013
let's watch clapper lie take a look does
the NSA collect any type of data at all
on millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not
not wittingly there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly Oh clapper was lying
through his teeth right there well that
seems to be the standard operating
procedure for all these Obama deep state
actors alright point three the committee
found house Intel committee zero
evidence of president Trump's pre
campaign business dealings resulting in
any kind of collusion point four they
conclude no evidence that Trump
associates were involved with WikiLeaks
publishing stolen Democratic emails this
is another liberal media fantasy that's
getting shot down by the way with all
the countries that hacked into Hillary's
server who knows who got those Wyck who
gave it to WikiLeaks there's one of a
dozen choices
here's my prediction pretty easy to get
this run right the rest of the liberal
media is not going to report this
tonight because it proves them to be
liars and phony in their quest for
journalism and truth this is all a
disinformation campaign and it's gone on
way too long
finally tonight I known going long Sarah
Carter brand new news reporting headline
Robert Muller Andrew Weissman the FBI
and the mob Sarah detailing how both
Muller Wiesmann are directly involved in
two of the biggest scandals in FBI
history when Muller was an acting US
Attorney in Boston in the 80s all he was
involved in the FBI's corrupt highly
unethical relationship with the infamous
murderer mobster Whitey Bulger four men
ended up being framed for murder sent to
jail two of them died in jail then it
resulted in over a hundred million
dollars in damages to the two that lived
and then there's Muller's pit bull
Andrew Weissman the rotten out apple
doesn't fall very far from the tree he's
the guy in 1990s organized crime case
Weitzman was reprimanded by a judge for
withholding exculpatory evidence and his
powerful friend well later were out
there to get him out of trouble we also
told you about Weissman's hard-charging
tactics in the Enron case tens of
thousands of people lost their jobs at
Ender's Andersen accounting for Merrill
executives go to jail that case was
overturned 9-0 against him all of this
information is shocking that's Muller's
team but given what we know about Muller
and his pit bull Weissman well it's now
par for the course this is at the
national disgrace what's happening